and you checking out the movies these  days you excited about anything coming  up well I know that that you're gonna  talk about it then yeah the girl no the  girl on the tree that's right I've been  reading a lot about girl in the Train I  love thriller Emily Blunt yeah it opens  this weekend girl on the train and  everyone's saying you know it's gonna be  great  it's based on the very popular book of  the same name and it's interesting I saw  an advanced screening oh you do yeah  lucky yeah yeah I saw an advanced  screening cuz you know you're not I mean  I didn't see you there anyway I saw I  think let me see an advanced screening  and so I went and I was excited to see  this but I have to tell you I watched  the movie I'm not sure they captured the  magic of the book I just don't think  they did take a look  [Music]  [Applause]  just didn't grab me yeah  seemed kind of artsy yeah  [Laughter]  you